ces événements ont plongé paris sourit
zoo c'est le scénario du pire tant
redouté par les pouvoirs publics
paris et sa région les pieds dans l'eau
des centaines de milliers de franciliens
inondées et paniquer et toute l'île de
france paralysée ce qui relève encore de
la fiction pourrait devenir un jour
réalité et c'est pour éviter cette
catastrophe que la structure épicène
sensibilise le grand public aux risques
d'inondations en ile de france
ce jour là les participants doivent
collaborer pour résoudre en moins d'une
heure un escape game
il vous reste quoi comme j'ai leur
mission du jour échappés ensemble à la
crue centennale de 2072 c'était assez
amusant c'était assez stressant aussi
avec le temps qui défile la lumière qui
s'éteint régulièrement sa manière
beaucoup plus intéressant de faire
passer des informations parce qu'on fait
en s'amusant et son côté potentiellement
anxiogène
alors je dis à papoter stressant mais
son côté anxiogène du fait que c'est une
inondation et oussalah vidéos mises en
situation et c'est sympa donc c'est pas
mal
que faire avant pendant et après une
crue dans une région plus d'un sondé sur
trois pense ne pas être exposés aux
risques d'inondations épicène se donne
pour objectif de former des acteurs
locaux
charge à eux ensuite de diffuser les
bonnes pratiques
on a quand même des gens qui connaissent
certaines choses mais qui sont toujours
en demande justement de savoir comment
transmettre le problème quand nous on
est spécialiste voilà hydrologue des
spécialistes du risque inondation le
plus important pour nous c'est bien
communiquer c'est de bien former les
gens c'est bien les sensibiliser et du
coup ce mode unie sarrassat huit cent
cinquante mille personnes et 620 mille
emplois installé en zone inondable les
enjeux sont colossaux pour la région
capitale le territoire habitué des
inondations avec deux crues importantes
en moins de cinq ans en juin 2016 le
niveau de la seine avait atteint six
mètres 10 bien loin encore de la crue
historique de 1910 et un pic à 8 mètres
62e qui avaient alors bloqué la capitale
pendant plusieurs jours c'est un risque
qui est inéluctable c'est un phénomène
qui séculaire enfin millénaire qui s'est
déjà passé qui se reproduira de toute
façon il faut que les gens s'y prépare
il faut que les gens soient pro actifs
par rapport à ça elles n'attendent pas
ne se laisse pas surprendre
entre guillemets notamment en
ile-de-france où le risque est
prévisible l'eau monte en général d'un
mètre à un mètre cinquante par jour
donc on a à peu près en général deux à
trois jours pour se préparer
selon une récente étude internationale
une crue égale à celle de 1910 pourrait
produire jusqu'à 30 milliards d'euros de
dégâts et sinistré jusqu'à 5 millions de
franciliens